come with me to have lunch at tiffins and Animal Kingdom
this was our first time at Tiffins and we were so excited to try it
we have gone to the Nomad Lounge a ton of times
and that is located right next door
right off the bat you could tell that this was a fancier experience
it is a bit of a higher price point for dining in Disney
so we also had high expectations
hostess explain that all the art is supposed to be observed gallery style
so go walk around the rooms and enjoy the art
we started off with a couple of cocktails
and then immediately got the bread service and the octopus appetizers
the bread service was 10 out of 10 incredible
and the octopus was fork tender
which if you know how to cook octopus
that is difficult next we have the living off the land salad and the duo of pork
it was so fun to eat the lettuces that we saw growing at our
behind the seed store and they were especially delicious
we both agreed that this is one of our new favourite restaurants
and we will be coming back from the service to the food
this was by far one of our best Disney dining experiences
and as always at Disney there is a kids menu
if your kids are kind of picky eaters
they can still get regular things like chicken fingers or Mac and cheese
let me know in the comments
if you've ever eaten at tiffins
what your experience was and what your favourite Walt Disney World restaurant is
if you haven't tried tiffins it's time to go